- This is Vietnam, right?
Oh, wait.
- [Girl] I don't know.
- Or is that Vietnam?
- I think I'm gonna do well in this area.
Not so much this area.
- I'd say I don't know where anything is
other than Japan and China.
- I have no experience
with Asian geography,
and I'm Asian, so...
- [Voiceover] Please locate Laos.
- Laos.
- Come on, Laos.
- Laos. (buzz)
- Laos.
Hold up, I think that's--
- [Man] Laos. (buzz)
- It's down here, right?
- It's in here somewhere.
- [Man] Yep.
- Laos is there. (buzz)
Because that was just
screaming Laos to me.
- Boom.
- That's definitely Laos.
- [Man] Laos. (buzz)
(buzz)
- No, fuck it, I'm going with it. (buzz)
- Tit.
- [Together] Ohh.
- Shit.
- You know what, I didn't
even look down there.
- [Voiceover] Thailand.
- Thailand, that's one of the fun ones.
- Isn't this Thailand? (chime)
No, never mind.
- It looks like a frickin'
brain, so I'm gonna dissect it.
- Thailand, let's think about
what kind of foods they got.
- This is Thailand. (buzz)
- This is Thailand?
- [Man] No, I don't know.
- I don't know.
- Peanut stuff.
Where's good soil for peanuts?
- Oh my God, I've been to Thailand.
- It's in the shape of this long, weird T.
- Doesn't that look like a little duck?
- That does look like a duck.
- Quack, quack, quack.
You know that little duck, quack, quack.
I'm gonna go for the duck. (chime)
- It's this teeny one. (buzz)
- It was the duck!
- [Man in Hat] Oh, the duck!
- [Man in Hat] Yes, yes!
- Quack, quack, quack.
- Son of a--
- [Man] God!
- I knew it.
- [Man] Dang it.
- [Voiceover] Please locate Syria.
- Syria, boom, I know it's over here.
- Syria, I know her.
- There is war there.
- We should know this one, man.
- We gotta know this one.
- Where's Europe on this map?
The big one I think is a
country or a body of water.
- All right, let's go there. (buzz)
- That's a good call.
I like that too 'cause
that looks like a boner.
- (buzz) No, it's that (buzz), bam.
- [Together] Syria.
- [Voiceover] Look.
- Ohh!
- (chime) Yeah!
- [Woman] What the heck, Alan.
- Oh, we were so close.
- [Man in Hat] Oh my God!
- Hey, you know what, I'm really proud.
We went for the boner,
and we should've gone for the testicles.
- No, definitely, always
go for the testicles.
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Philippines.
- [Man in Glasses] Philippines,
that's an island, right?
- Well, I'm 1/8 Filipino,
so this one's gonna hurt.
- I have a lot of Filipino friends.
- You are Filipino.
- No, wait, don't put that on me.
- You're part Filipino,
and you don't know where
the Philippines are?
- I'm part Filipino. (chime)
So I've looked at it on
a map a bunch of times
even though I've never gone.
- This guy looks fun. (buzz)
- [Man in Hat] Yeah.
- And they're the Philippines.
Maybe it's all of this. (chime)
- Yeah, you know what, I
think it might be this little
- [Together] Cluster.
- (chime) Whoa.
That was you.
- Well, yes.
- Yes, yes!
- [Man in Glasses] Yeah.
Of course, we had to know that too
'cause we have a huge Filipino fan base.
Pretty sure I showed him what
was probably the Philippines,
and he's like, "Yeah,
you know what, it is."
- I don't think so.
- Maybe it's all of this.
- Yeah, you know what...
- [Voiceover] Iran.
- [Man in Glasses] Iran.
- Just piling on the guilt.
- I get confused with Iraq and Iran.
- This one (buzz) or this one (buzz)?
- This one we should know, like this...
- (buzz) Believe that's Iran.
- Iran. (chime)
- I think it's this one. (buzz)
No wait, it's this. (buzz)
Oh fuck, that might be Iraq, God damn it.
- [Man in Glasses] What
does your heart say?
- I think it's this one
for some reason. (buzz)
- If that's your heart, go for it.
Always follow your heart.
- This is Iran. (chime)
- I was right.
- [Man in Hat] Oh, no!
- Wow!
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Bangladesh.
- Bangladesh is near India
because their food is similar.
India.
- I'm pretty sure that's India.
- So, Bangladesh is either...
- Here or what about here?
- (buzz) Bangladesh is here.
It's part of a jumble of other countries.
- [Woman] Okay, so...
- Bam. (chime)
I don't know.
- So you think it's this one.
- I mean the only other one
it could be is here. (buzz)
- Unless it's this one. (buzz)
- It just is kind of stuck in there.
Like when you bang someone. (chime)
- That's Bangladesh.
- (chime) Hey!
- [Man in Hat] Yes!
We're killin' it.
- (chime) Good guess, exactly.
- [Man] Good job, good job.
- (chime) Ohh, what's up!
What's up!
- I will totally sell Ryan down the river,
and his initial thought
that that was China.
He's like, "Well, that's
China, obviously."
- And I'll deny that 'til the day I die.